Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Tutti noi abbiamo un sogno,
un'aspirazione.
Il mio sogno personale,
da biologa e ricercatrice,
è quello che si possa,
in un prossimo futuro, un vicino futuro,
riuscire a fare ricerca biomedica
senza sofferenza.
Forse lo sapete:
ogni anno, milioni di animali
vengono sacrificati per fare ricerca.
Li utilizziamo, ad esempio,
per testare gli effetti
di sostanze potenzialmente tossiche
per la salute umana;
ma anche per studiare le malattie umane.
Tuttavia, quello che sta emergendo,
negli ultimi anni,
è che la sperimentazione animale
è intrinsecamente incerta.
Pensate che la capacità predittiva
dei test sugli animali,
ovvero la capacità di predire
possibili effetti tossici
per la salute umana
testando una sostanza sugli animali,
è piuttosto bassa.
Non è molto dissimile
dal lancio di una monetina.
Questa bassa capacità predittiva,
potete ben immaginare,
non agevola la salvaguardia
della salute umana.
Troppo spesso, molto spesso,
scopriamo gli effetti tossici
di alcune sostanze, o di alcuni farmaci,
direttamente sull’essere umano,
sugli uomini, le donne.
Quando invece, prima,
questa stessa sostanza,
questo stesso farmaco
non avevano generato
particolari effetti sospetti nell'animale.
Chiediamoci poi un'altra cosa:
di quali animali stiamo parlando?
Perlopiù parliamo di questi,
di roditori: topi e ratti.
L’80% circa degli animali
usati per fare ricerca.
Topi e ratti, nei confronti dei quali
non proviamo grande simpatia.
Diciamocelo francamente:
ci disgustano, a volte!
Eppure questi animaletti
provano sentimenti, ed empatia,
come è stato dimostrato
da numerose ricerche.
Ma oltre che di roditori parliamo, anche,
di conigli, di cani, di gatti,
di anfibi, di uccelli, di pesci.
Parliamo perfino di primati non umani
tipo scimmie, scimpanzè.
Per quanto riguarda
la ricerca biomedica, nello specifico,
nuovamente, il topo è la specie più usata.
E parlando di ricerca biomedica,
facciamo un esempio su tutti: l’Alzheimer.
Per quanto riguarda
l'Alzheimer, per l'appunto,
i topi geneticamente modificati
sono di fatto la specie
che va per la maggiore.
Si ritengono utili, questi topi,
poiché attraverso di essi
è possibile studiare
alcuni dei tratti patologici
dell'Alzheimer,
come ad esempio l'accumulo
di proteine amiloidi.
Tuttavia, quello che ormai si sa
è che questi animali
non sviluppano realmente l'Alzheimer,
ma solamente alcuni tratti patologici
di questa complessa sindrome.
Pensate inoltre che,
attraverso questi topi,
in realtà si può studiare
relativamente l'Alzheimer.
Sviluppano la patologia
in giorni, o settimane.
Quando invece, nell'essere umano,
l'Alzheimer richiede decenni
per consolidarsi.
E questo aspetto del tempo ci porta
ad un’altra importante riflessione.
Tempo, o krònos, dal greco.
Le patologie croniche, e degenerative,
richiedono tempo a manifestarsi.
E in questo tempo, lo potete
ben immaginare da voi stessi,
lo stile di vita
gioca un ruolo fondamentale.
Nutrizione, attività fisica,
allenamento cognitivo,
perfino la qualità del nostro sonno,
il microbioma intestinale:
tutto gioca un ruolo fondamentale
nella determinazione del rischio
di queste patologie.
E come potete nuovamente intuire,
l'utilizzo dei modelli animali,
in questo senso, non aiuta molto.
È pressoché impossibile riprodurre,
in una specie diversa dall'essere umano,
tutti questi fattori
così intrinsecamente collegati
allo stile di vita umano.
Vedete bene la nostra anatomia,
la nostra fisiologia,
il nostro sistema immunitario,
il modo in cui interagiamo
e reagiamo agli stimoli esterni
differiscono sostanzialmente
fra le specie animali.
Un esempio su tutti è lo scimpanzè.
Pensate: lo scimpanzè
è la specie a noi più vicina.
Tra uomo e scimpanzè,
dal punto di vista genetico,
c'è solo un 2% di differenza.
Ma è nel passaggio da geni a proteine
che si riscontra ben l’80% di diversità.
Queste diversità tra le specie,
così come anche i possibili
effetti avversi, imprevedibili,
che la sperimentazione scientifica
può avere sulle cavie
sono alcuni dei fattori
alla base della crisi di riproducibilità
in ambito scientifico.
Questa crisi di riproducibilità
si riscontra, anche,
dal punto di vista dei test sui farmaci.
I test sui farmaci,
prima di arrivare all’uomo,
prevedono i test sugli animali,
i test preclinici.
Tuttavia, qui,
si riscontrano dei problemi:
assistiamo ad un 90%, di media,
di fallimento di ciò
che viene testato negli animali.
Perché nel 90% dei casi, semplicemente,
non funziona per gli esseri umani.
Anche qui facciamo
un esempio: l'Alzheimer.
Uno studio del 2014
ha preso in considerazione
244 farmaci, pensate,
testati in ben 413 trial clinici
nel decennio che va dal 2002 al 2012.
Solamente un farmaco, su 244,
ha passato tutte le fasi:
dalla fase preclinica,
fase 1, fase 2, fase 3.
Questo si traduce
in un tasso del fallimento
equivalente a quello
che vedete scritto qui: 99,6%.
È un tasso di fallimento inaccettabile.
Attualmente, per l'Alzheimer
abbiamo di fatto quattro farmaci.
E questi quattro farmaci
sono pressoché inutili
nella prognosi a lungo termine,
funzionano solamente
in una minima parte di pazienti,
e conferiscono benefici
minimi, se non nulli.
È possibile che uno dei fattori
alla base di questo fallimento
in ambito preclinico
sia legato alla sovrastima
e al sovrautilizzo dei modelli animali
per lo studio delle patologie umane.
Ebbene, che fare dunque?
Beh, le patologie umane
si possono innanzitutto studiare
sugli esseri umani:
esistono numerosissimi studi clinici,
osservazionali, interventistici,
che hanno dimostrato essere
estremamente utili
per cogliere informazioni utili all'uomo,
e realmente efficaci, anche,
nel disegnare nuovi farmaci.
Campioni di sangue biologico,
campioni di liquido cerebrospinale,
collezionamento di biopsie post-mortem,
uniti a tecniche di neuroimaging,
così come anche a colture cellulari
derivate da pazienti,
rappresentano delle fonti insostituibili,
ed incredibilmente utili,
per studiare le malattie.
Qui, al Centro Comune di Ricerca,
dove ci occupiamo anche
della convalida, validazione, promozione
di metodi alternativi
alla sperimentazione animale,
usiamo queste cellule:
cellule umane differenziate in neuroni.
Queste colture neuronali
vengono utilizzate
per testare gli effetti
di sostanze potenzialmente tossiche,
neurotossiche appunto.
Ma modelli molto simili a questo,
anche più complessi di questo,
cresciuti in 3D, in tridimensionalità,
possono già oggi essere utilizzati
per studiare le patologie umane.
Anche, ad esempio,
per formulare nuovi farmaci.
Questo sta già succedendo,
nell'ambito dell'Alzheimer.
Modelli simili a questo
possono essere integrati
ad approcci in silico, computazionali,
per definire i meccanismi molecolari
che sono alla base delle patologie,
al fine, anche, di trovare
nuove possibili strategie di cura,
sia farmacologica che non.
C'è un però:
la strada che porterà
all’ampia accettazione,
alla convalida di questi metodi,
è ancora un po' lunga.
Pensate che l'Unione Europea,
già del 2013,
ha messo al bando
la sperimentazione animale
per testare i cosmetici.
Se però nel settore della cosmetica,
ma soprattutto della tossicologia
in senso più lato,
la sperimentazione animale,
e i suoi limiti,
è già discussa da parecchio tempo,
e i nuovi metodi stanno avanzando,
è nel settore della medicina,
e della sperimentazione biomedica,
che si riscontrano delle restrizioni
e delle difficoltà.
L’utilizzo di animali
nella sperimentazione animale
è semplicemente considerata obbligatoria,
perché a norma di legge.
È inoltre regolamentata
anche dai codici etici,
definiti nella dichiarazione di Helsinki
e nel codice di Norimberga
dalla Seconda Guerra Mondiale in poi.
Per cui, di fatto,
di strada ce n'è da fare.
Però c'è anche da chiedersi,
alla luce degli evidenti fallimenti
in ambito traslazionale,
dal modello animale all’umano,
e anche alla luce della disponibilità
di nuovi metodi attualmente disponibili,
di nuove tecnologie,
perfino di tecnologie
di medicina personalizzata
che permetterebbero, di fatto,
di creare dei nuovi trattamenti
su misura per ogni singolo paziente,
forse oggi i tempi sono maturi
per ragionare, speculare sulla possibilità
di un cambiamento di paradigma
anche nell'ambito della ricerca biomedica.
E ovviamente,
questo cambiamento di paradigma
passa per che cosa?
Passa per nuovi
approcci normativi, certamente;
ma passa anche per un'ampia discussione
che deve essere fatta
con la comunità scientifica in generale,
e con gli enti finanziatori della ricerca,
sull'importanza reale
di investire risorse ed energie
in metodi che siano:
più rilevanti per l'essere umano;
eticamente accettabili;
ed ecologicamente sostenibili.
Qui stiamo parlando anche
di un approccio diverso alla ricerca,
da un approccio mentale
più riduzionistico,
dove si prende
il singolo pezzo di un puzzle
e si cerca di studiarlo e riprodurlo
in una specie animale
piuttosto che in una coltura di cellule,
ad un approccio molto più olistico,
complesso e multidimensionale
in cui gli esseri viventi
vengono riconcepiti
non più come tanti pezzetti
di un solo puzzle,
ma come esseri complessi
in relazione all'ambiente che li circonda,
al fine di cogliere l’interezza
e l’integrazione delle loro parti.
Inoltre stiamo anche parlando di coraggio,
affinché questo paradigma cambi.
Coraggio e determinazione.
Il coraggio, ad esempio,
di uscire dalla propria zona di confort.
Il coraggio di ammettere
che alcune teorie
devono essere riconsiderate,
lì dove risultino obsolete.
E ovviamente, io vi lascio
con questo mio sogno personale,
che torna un po' a quello
che dicevo all'inizio.
Io penso che già da oggi sia possibile
fare ricerca biomedica senza sofferenza.
Gli strumenti ci sono e la conoscenza c'è.
E pensiamo un'altra cosa:
la sofferenza di cui sto parlando
non è solamente la sofferenza
degli animali usati per fare ricerca.
È anche la sofferenza
di quei milioni di pazienti
che ogni giorno aspettano
delle cure realmente efficaci,
che tardano ad arrivare
e che potrebbero, addirittura,
non arrivare mai,
se si continua a seguire, e a perseguire,
nell'utilizzo di approcci fuorvianti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)